what song are you gonna do for us
acoustically I can't wait for this
tonight tonight
one of my favorite toys I get you
requested this so I did I love this song
I and I'm gonna say this right now I
would not do this for anybody well I am
blessed that you will do this I am I'm
just such a fan of yours when you wrote
this song is there any particular memory
of writing it that how this comes to you
the song actually took a little while to
write it was in it actually and
originally in a different key I think it
was instead of like this part it was
kind of like
[Music]
and I kind of have like some kind of
demo of it from maybe 94 but no lyrics
anything how's it work for you do you
obviously you get the music first so you
don't have any lyrics you just go you go
okay I hear this chord progression in my
head I honestly I don't have a lot of
memory of writing the song right I kind
of I remember what I was thinking which
was that for example the song pays a
little bit of homage to cheap trick I
love cheap great rock and roll bands and
cheap trick occasionally would have this
kind of dark optimistic thing you know
like they'd sing about something that
seemed kind of bright but inside was
kind of dark like daddy's alright yeah
mommy's alright but they just seem like
heaven tonight as an example so right I
think I was kind of thinking a little
bit of that kind of cheap trick vibe
where it's like it's it's on the surface
it seems kind of like hopeful and stuff
and idealistic but if you kind of dig
into the lyric a little bit it's got
some darkness in it yeah cuz you think
about it like that it does sound hopeful
this song yeah but I do get depressed
which is cool
that when I hear it when we had the song
I mean I thought it was a good song but
I mean I never would have guessed it
turned out to be what it's become I mean
it's become basically a classic in a way
that's almost probably more important
than any other song I've ever written
oh it's fantastic it's a generational
marker or something you know it reminds
people of times and and that's a good
feeling I'm I never would have guessed
that when I wrote it for sure I'd love
to hear you do it here's the great Billy
Corgan
doing one of his classics
[Music]
[Music]
time is never time upon you can never l
mean without leaving a piece of you it
allows the forever changed we will never
be the same the more you change the less
you feel
[Music]
he changed it you're not stuck in vain
[Music]
so fries
[Music]
tonight
[Music]
and you know we never shut but you sure
you can't be right
if you held yourself up to the side
MEMS never fade
in your city violate place
[Music]
the
leave me leave
[Music]
I don't see
interview believes neither cheese
tonight
[Music]
tonight
[Music]
tonight
by the insincere tonight
[Applause]
make things right
all tonight
and wait upper up the night
in the scrap of
moments of your life
[Music]
Bassem
today
even mr. Lee
you tonight tonight
ah
tonight
[Music]
fantastic I think oh my goodness that is
just beautiful